the sentence against rights activist
adilu Rahman Khan and nasruddin ilam
came down in a crowded courtroom in
Dhaka several members of human rights
groups and representatives from foreign
missions attended including the U.N U.S
Canada and the United Kingdom the
defense and prosecution said they were
not happy with the decision to send the
men to prison for two years both sides
will file an appeal at the high court
as a defense lawyer I think the
government has simply failed to prove
its case prosecution was unable to
submit any valid documents to
substantiate their allegations
as a state prosecutor we expected a most
significant and longer sentence in this
case we are planning to appeal this
verdict
a week before the verdict right activist
adilu Rahman Khan and nasrid then Ilan
spoke to Al Jazeera about the various
rights violation by Security Forces they
have compiled over the years
in the democratic system in the
Democratic countries human rights
organizations human rights Defenders are
allowed to function
but unfortunately we have
authoritarian system and under
authoritarianism
human rights is something
which is foreign
[Music]
the information communication Act is a
repressive law it's widely used against
those with dissenting voices and against
opposition political party members so
that no one can speak out against the
government and is designed to create an
atmosphere of fear
their groups of the car has been
documenting abuses in Bangladesh since
1994 and has worked with the United
Nations
this case relates to a report they
published 10 years ago accusing security
forces of excessive force and
extrajudicial killings the U.S European
Union Parliament members Amnesty
International and other rights
organization have urged the authorities
here to immediately release the
activists
the jail sentence verdict of two leading
rights activists is bound to have a
chilling effect on civil society and
human rights Defenders at large in
Bangladesh digital security on Thursday
Bangladesh is law Minister an isilah
said it's not possible to dismiss cases
filed under a special digital Security
Act which activists say has been used to
crack down on descent
in Democratic countries human rights
organizations and human rights Defenders
are allowed to function unfortunately we
have an authoritarian system under
authoritarianism human rights is
something which is foreign this is the
first time in Bangladesh's 52-year
history rights Defenders have been
sentenced to prison for reporting on
violations
critics and rights groups are instead of
independently investigating and
responding to the findings of odika's
Report with facts the authorities have
chosen instead to punish the human
rights activists for doing their work
sandwich
Brazil's top quarters handed out
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera